- Ah, bien!
pas son enthousiasme au moment
de présenter sa nouvelle
candidate dans
Chutes-d
- Martine, c'est une femme
de tête, une femm.
Je pense qu'elle va faire
sa marque en politique.30 ans en
journalisme, Martine Biron fait
le saut en politique.
Celle qui occupait un rôle
explique que sa décision a été
prise récemment, durant
ses vacances. Son impartialité
journalistique, assure-t-ellis .
MARTINE BIRON, candidate, CAQ
Chutes-de-la-Chaudière
- Je sais que j'ai fait
L'éthique, j'ai bâti ma carrière
sur l'éthique. Je ne pouvais pas
sortir avec un manque d'éthique.
les nombreuses candidatures
de journalistes en
prochaines élections, soulèvent
des questions légitimes au sein
- Il y a peut-être
une conversation à avoir
puis s'il y en a une, ça va
- Mais le premier défi de
la candidate vedette sera
de convaqu'elle appuie le projet
de troisième lien dans
la région de Québec.
Comme analyste, Martine Biron
démontrant la pertinence
de l'ouvrage. Elle se dit
maintenant convaincue
- Quiconque vit à Québec sait
que ça poisième lien.
- Par le passé, Martine Biron a
aussi eu des mots  élus de la C.
À la fin de la dernière
session, elle n'hésitait pas
à souligner l'arrogance de
- J'ai parlé de GenevièveGuilba,
de sa grosse tête, mais en même
temps, j
cette fille-là était surdouée.
GENEVIÈVE GUILB
vice-première ministre du Québec
- Moi, je ne lui en tiens pasndl
que vous avez à faire.
- La principale intéressée jure
avoir passé l'éponge, mais
aux côtés de la nouvelle recrue.
certainement,
je lui donne sa chance!
- Écoute, on a troisiètroisiètÇe
comment ils vont s'ouvrir
là-dessus.
- Sur la Rive-Sud, les appuis
frisent les 65 %.
Et le Parti conservateur compte
bien marteler que la nouvelle
véritablement en faveur
du projet.
ÉRIC DUHAIME, chef, Parti
conservateur du Québecus.
Ces gens-là vous mentent.
- Le ton est donné
pour la